the ftth conferences the largest  fibre-to-the-home event in the world  since its first edition in 2004 the  annual FTTH conference has grown  exponentially and today welcomes more  than 3,300 visitors from 85 countries  the event combines three key elements a  high-level conference including VIP  speakers and several hands-on workshops  a huge exhibition area with all the  latest technologies from more than 100  key market players and amazing  networking opportunities meet with the  world's leading industry experts  policymakers telecom operators  application developments investors  analysts media and many others and  discover our amazing fiber enabled world  of applications demo area